When people socialize with the wrong crowd,
bad things can happen.
They may form questionable values and develop
poor attitudes towards law and order.
And if their friends are criminals, they naturally
learn from them and over time adopt their
way of life.
Psychologically, this process is known as
differential association.
Differential association theory is the work
of Edwin Sutherland, who spent his life studying
principles of criminology, and found 9 distinct
precepts.
To learn how this works in real life, let's
see how Robbin, a shy 14 year old boy, ends
up in jail.
Criminal behavior is learned.
Robbin learns it after meeting a new friend.
It is learned through interaction and conversation
with others, often supported by storytelling.
This learning process takes place primarily
in small and intimate groups.
Books, video games, and mass media have little
impact.
The learning of criminal behavior includes
sharing insights and techniques as well as
reasons and attitudes that favor criminal
actions.
Motives are learned by dividing the legal
system into good laws and bad laws.
Robbin learns that the laws protecting poor
people’s property are good, while the laws
protecting rich people’s property are bad.
We become delinquent once our rationale for
breaking the law outweighs our rationale for
respecting it.
Robbin steals once he believes that he needs
to take from the rich to give to the poor.
Our learning experiences vary in frequency,
duration, the priority we give them, and how
intense they are.
Robbin’s time as a criminal is over when
he and his friends all get arrested.
Learning criminal behavior is like learning
anything else.
Robbin learns this just like his sister learns
math — the same mechanisms are involved.
Although criminal behavior is an expression
of one’s needs and values, it is not explained
by them.
Non-criminal behavior can also stem from the
exact same needs and values.
Edwin Sutherland was an American sociologist
whose work had a big impact on criminal policy.
His theory recognizes that criminal attitudes
can be learnt socially.
Consequently, they can also be unlearned.
In other words, Sutherland helped us understand
that kids like Robbin can be rehabilitated.
What do you think?
How can we help keep society free from crimes
that happen, on the street and in the top
floors of big corporations?
And if Sutherland was right, is jail the right
place for young offenders?
Please share your thoughts in the comments
below!
This and all other Sprouts' videos are licensed
under the Creative Commons.
That means teachers from all around the world
can use them in classrooms, online courses
or
to start projects - and today, thousands already
do!
To learn how it works and download this video
without Ads or background music, checkout
our website or read the description below.
If you want to support our mission and help
change education
visit our Patreon - that's patreon.com/sprouts.